the one thing that was that was
important to me was the fact that the
education system was very tolerant of a
late bloomer in high school I would
bring home so-called check marks for
does not respect authority and I was not
a very I might my performance in high
school was erratic
certain teachers picked up on the fact
that I had some talent but but but I was
not I did not perform vertically well
and the University I went to it happened
to be the one where my dad was Provost
but it's a local university and that
that admits a large number of people and
just being able to go to a university
having some key faculty members kind of
identify you as a person that might have
some counted interest and I'm invest in
and and kind of allowing me as a late
bloomer to still engage in embark on a
career was tremendously important so I
guess the message would be first of all
don't give up on yourself early on and
and it's good to be in environments that
can tolerate late bloomers